someone told this guy to be there or be
square and he took it literally
got him okay so the second season of the
umbrella academy ends with a big
cliffhanger
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down everything we know so
far about the mysterious sparrow academy
we'll also be going over lila and how
she may actually tie into the group
themselves
so make sure you stick around until the
end as we've got a big theory on her
inclusion
obviously there's gonna be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to watch
season two yet then what the hell are
you doing i heard a rumor that you watch
the entire thing
if you're still here then welcome to the
heavy spoiler show i'm your host
definition aka
youtube's number two now let's get into
the video
okay so lila pitts is one of the big
newcomers in season two
that ends up becoming attached to the
umbrella academy
in several ways like the members of the
group
she was born on october 1st 1989 with
her mother showing
little to no signs of pregnancy unlike
the family though
lila was not adopted by sir reginald
hargreaves and instead
she was raised by her parents in london
after realizing that superpowered beings
may one day lead to the downfall of all
life itself
the handler decided that she needed to
build her own army of soldiers
and thus she started to put a plan into
action because there were 43 children
all born with special abilities this
massive number could
vastly overwhelm any army on earth and
the character came to the conclusion
that
she would need to match them on a level
playing field so she started to study
the individuals that would add the most
to her army
and this is when she came across the one
size fits all solution to her problem
lila lila has the ability to mimic those
with superpowers
and she's very much about taking one's
strength and turning it into a weakness
due to years of practice lila is able to
completely master someone's abilities
within an instant
though her powers are limited to one
person at a time
we see this demonstrated a great success
in the finale when he tells allison
to stop breathing and yeah you know what
you went too far
now we discovered that the handler was
responsible for lila's parents deaths in
1993
and that she hired number five to kill
them in case you don't know
the thames commission travel through
time assassinating people that may
eventually become problematic
and the handler made the job seem like
the utmost importance to five
hiding the truth about her true
intentions after five had disposed of
the pair
the handler took the child and then
started to train her
lila is already an expert in
hand-to-hand combat and add to this her
mimic abilities
yeah she's not one to be messed with
because she's so good at adapting and
fitting to any situation
the handler sent her to stalk diego
hargreaves and when he was committed to
an insane asylum for trying to stop the
assassination of jfk
she soon became a member of the
institution lyla led to the character's
escape
and this made diego trust her as the
handler's mole
she kept tabs on their operations in the
past and even kidnapped diego at one
point in the hopes of getting him to
sign up to the temps
instead of falling madly in love with
her though he simply used it as an
opportunity to learn about what caused
the apocalypse in the 60s
and after this she felt very betrayed
the handler twisted the knife even
further
pinning the death of her parents on five
and this led to her
absolutely hating the group delilah
joined her surrogate mother in the
finale to take down the academy
and it's at this point that she learned
about the truth upon asking the handler
if what five told her was true the last
of the swedes arrived and shot her
which is when lila decided to grab the
temps briefcase and flee to parts
unknown
that's the last we saw of her but she
may have ended up in the sparrow academy
which we'll get into in just a bit
now the name of these actually comes
from the comics themselves
volume 3 titled hotel oblivion centers
around the rise of superpowered lunatics
in the world
and during the final battle all of the
villains that the heroes have ever
locked up
are freed from their captivity this of
course ties into the title hotel
oblivion
which is an interdimensional prison that
houses the bad guys
the heroes are overwhelmed but a group
known as the sparrows
show up and save them on top of this
gerard way has officially announced that
the fourth volume in the run will be
known as the sparrow academy
in an interview with forbes wei stated
the following
it deals with a very big reveal in the
umbrella academy universe
something that's been secret for a long
time our siblings learn
a lot about what was happening behind
the scenes as well as discovering the
true nature of some characters
that have been with them since the
beginning the series finally starts to
answer the question
what about the other babies born on that
day in that moment
the umbrella academy siblings are not
alone in the world anymore
now as for the show i do believe that
the sparrow academy is connected with
harlan in some way
at the end of the series we see that the
character is levitating a sparrow
and in this timeline it is possible that
he became the first superpowered being
on the planet
and thus set an example for what was to
come it could be that the sparrow
academy are named after him
but we won't know until we see the next
season for ourselves
sparrows are actually laced throughout
the series at several key points
and popbuzz.com recently put together a
full list on every location of the
little bird
which does hint towards their importance
in the world now how they were formed we
don't know
but personally i believe that after
meeting the original hargreaves in the
sixties
surregional decided that they were
complete screw-ups
and this adopted seven other individuals
as he never met ben
due to the character being a ghost he
didn't have the foresight to avoid
choosing him
and this scooped him up though it seems
like this may have also been a bad
choice
now as for the group the big elephant in
the room is of course
well ben in the original timeline the
character died while still on the job
however here he is live and kicking
looking like a my chemical romance fan
that just discovered their top 10 songs
video by watch mojo
sorry gerard ben is probably the most
that we know about the group power wise
as we can take a lot of his abilities
from the original timeline
and just bring them across now when the
character was part of the original
lineup
he was called number six in case you
don't know when har greaves formed the
group
he assigned them a number from one to
seven this was originally thought to be
their power level with one being the top
however over the years it became clear
that this was actually the ranking of
their obedience to him
and if anything the more powerful were
were further down the list
with vania who was seven not being in
this timeline
ben therefore becomes the most powerful
and
it's pretty clear that it's gone to his
head and also his fringe
now ben actually possesses the ability
to summon eldritch monsters from another
dimension
the portal to which just so happens to
be under his skin
thus when he attacks it looks like
tentacles are emerging from his stomach
growing up due to ben's naivety he was
easily manipulated
and har greaves often put him on the
front line which clearly led to his
death
this ben that we see likely possesses
the same powers
though by the looks of it he's in
control and not hargreaves
it is possible that in the original
timeline due to the family being very
submissive to their father
that he just got in line and didn't
fight back perhaps the sparrows gave as
good as they got
and this empowered him to take the lead
and even hang a lovely lovely picture of
himself
up in the main hall either way he's
clearly the leader
but who exactly is he in charge of well
in the comic books
the sparrows are introduced to vonye as
a real family
they all wear red she's from russia and
therefore there may be some connection
there
especially since the show seems to
center around the tensions between
america and the country
the first person that we know for
definite is caller and she
is pretty much the allison of the group
caller is able to alter reality through
her
voice but instead of saying i heard a
rumor the character says i said so
and this spends everything to her will
in case you don't know in the comics
vonya is paralyzed and carla actually
manages to fix her legs just by willing
it's so
she takes vania to norway which is where
we are introduced to the sparrows
and we get a tease of who exactly they
are the next up in the lineup is number
one
who seems like the luther of the group
however
unlike the one we've come to know and be
be a bit
so so on i guess i'm not going to say
love he hasn't been experimented on
and is more of a normal person next up
is the weird-looking blob-like character
and though they seem pretty messed up
this is actually because they're a human
voodoo doll that's able to inflict
injury on others by hurting themselves
they've clearly had to completely
destroy their body and
face in order to do this and yeah it's
really really weird
i actually think that lila may be a
stand-in for this character
and though her powers aren't the same i
do think that when it comes down to it
she may actually be revealed as a member
of the group lila of course has
knowledge of the family
and she may have helped the reginald to
pick up the right children for his
mission
the big plot hole in reggie not choosing
the original children
is that he wouldn't know how to avoid
some of them and thus
i think lyla may have gave him a helping
hand due to her knowledge of the future
now that's all just a theory and i'm not
100 but i think it would be interesting
to see
there's also a member that's able to
vomit up a black bile-like substance
that melts armor
and severely damages people that come
into contact with it
then there's the member that can turn
into what is either a murder
of crows or more fittingly a flock of
sparrows
there's also a blonde girl who appears
beside them though
we don't know exactly what's going on
with her lastly is the levitating green
cube
which we know even less about than all
the rest there are several theories
floating about
excuse the pun and some believe that in
the absence of grace
that this may have taken up the position
of their mother leading them to be
somewhat anti-heroes however i actually
think that this may be the equivalent to
five
we know that other dimensions and
realities are laced throughout the
series
and is possible that just in the way
that five could jump through time
that the cube can jump through
dimensions i believe that
similar to how five became trapped in
his younger body
this cube was originally a person that
became trapped in a fourth dimensional
form
and is now able to move through time and
space this would counter five's
abilities
and make for the perfect opposite to him
which the majority of the sparrow
academy
actually seem to be on the whole i'm
sure we'll find out soon enough but
yeah floating cube guy being five that
makes the most sense to me
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts and theories so make sure you
comment below and let me know
if you want to know where we think the
show could be heading in the future
then make sure you check out our
predictions for season 3 after this
don't forget that every month on the
15th we give away free blu-rays
and all you have to do to be with a
chance of winning the mcu infinity saga
box set is leave a like
and subscribe with notifications on if
you want to support the channel and get
to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat to us on our
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been
definition and i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you